vodka Gregg Jess Jets is here we're
gonna watch this video from mr.
nightmare Channel awesome YouTube
channel one of my faves
five of the weirdest creepiest Pokemon
go encounters I have walked in on men
being sexually taken advantage of by
multiple black woman but I did catch a
Charmander so it was just close the door
after that we're done gotta go left
gotta catch them all sorry yeah couldn't
help you out there
mr. Wallace Tom Wallace senior vice
president of Crystal Geyser water with
everyone playing Pokemon go the game
that actually forces you to get outside
and walk around to find pokemon and
pretty much most biggest scavenger hunts
the app is creating a lot of laughs
whether they be for mixtures of Pokemon
and some pretty funny locations videos
of angry player reactions however with
so many people suddenly exploring places
they never would have otherwise some are
finding things they weren't supposed to
find or perhaps getting into situations
they don't want to be in sweet
number one a story just about
everybody's heard about by now is 19
year old Sheila Wiggins from Wyoming
finding a dead body Shayla was told to
find a Pokemon in a natural water source
but instead found a man's course she was
walking towards a bridge along the shore
when she saw something in the water
and after taking a second look she
realized it was a body
Sheila is currently living in a trailer
park for the summer with her mother and
in said trailer park Shayla hopped a
fence to get to the Pokemon shown on her
map yes the body was found in the big
wind river
however there didn't appear to be any
foul play involved and was ruled
accidental
likely a drowning the Sheriff's
Department is still currently looking
into it plate as of right now the actual
story behind the death remains unknown
Kyra Sydow Kayla of course did not catch
the Pokemon [ __ ] number 2
Jess got cute but for her the other
player of the game shared his experience
on reddit the 32 year old men explained
how he found himself hunting for Pokemon
for the first time at 4 in the morning
walking home from work after working the
night shift and later encountered about
5 sketchy-looking men from his own words
on his late-night stroll the man told
reddit of the little park that he must
pass on his way home every night the
park had two pokey stops in a gym so he
decided to walk through the park this
one time just to see exactly what the
stops were for and what they did
somewhere through the park however the
man ran into a group of five younger
guys three black to white they all
looked as though they were in the middle
of a drug deal one of the guys called
him over to wide eyes reward they
started to follow him and before he
could even decide to run away or not the
sound of two police cars quickly pulling
up on the road alongside the park froze
everyone in their spots so now the group
was reported by an anonymous resident
for a potential drug deal which actually
turned out to be the case the man though
questioned was let go shortly after
number three was that matter to the
Pokemon company's dismay many players or
trainers as they refer to them have been
victims of robbery
in fact different youtubers have
actually posted video footage of
themselves getting robbed while playing
the game for example youtuber Aiden's
life and that's when I found this
yeah yo so clean up we're going what
what the [ __ ] going be serious that
real that's not real seeing something
like this happen to someone who's so
unsuspecting is scary and something like
this has apparently been happening every
day because a poem Anka cases so far was
the story of a group of armed robbers
apparently targeting victims using the
game who had done so successfully up to
eight times I squared $14 apprehended by
police in O'Fallon Missouri on Sunday
after allegedly robbing a 33 year old
man most of you know the app contains
pokey stops which are randomly placed on
notable locations and towns where
players can earn points pokeballs and
make purchases quarks later has to
actually walk to that location to earn
the points which are available to all
players the game also features a lore
module which attracts Pokemon to a
specific pokey stop this invites other
players to come to the location and
collect Pokemon as well this is exactly
how these four teenagers award
unsuspecting players mostly kids to this
specific location where they rob them
brilliant
one of the victims shared his experience
explaining them the symphony walking to
a pokey stop in the night when three
guys came out from behind a parked band
with the hand gun demanding money two of
the robbers were 18 years old 117 and
another 16 the 16 year old is the only
robber not being charged as an adult
obviously number four sound more than
one dead body has already been found by
Pokemon go players not even two weeks
after release three women playing the
game found a dead body on Thursday the
14th near a creek bed in the san diego
park
the three women were walking on a tree
while hunting for Pokemon at about 3
p.m. and marionberry Memorial Park when
they stumbled into the body of a man who
had been dead for quite some time geez
one of the women had apparently picked
up on the very pungent and foul odor and
that's when they noticed the body laying
in a patch of bushes near the bed
police believe foul play is a
possibility but his death will be
further investigated but that's not even
it with the dead bodies more believe it
but yet another Pokemon go player has
stumbled into a dead body this man's
body was recovered the same past
Thursday afternoon from a small stream
behind the New Hampshire Holocaust
Memorial in Nashua after it was spotted
by someone playing the game
oh come on go as well because my not
your spot where you found the body as of
right now the police don't believe that
foul play was involved the police are
however becoming more and more grateful
for the discoveries that the app is
leading to in fact some police forces
are already using the app to lure
fugitives to certain locations that's
now I can't necessarily verify if this
last one is a hundred percent true or
not but this one comes from a redditor
named SD skate Liske
there we go switch has since been
deleted sharing something really scary
that happened to him while playing
Pokemon Gus good the redditor stated
that he's 13 years old and then a really
creepy couple moved in across the street
from him a couple who could always be
heard arguing within a certain radius
from their house Jess Harper's already
reported on his stoop and watched a kid
playing Pokemon go around the block one
late night close to midnight he was
playing the game doing his usual laps
around the block when he noticed one of
the pokey stops on the block which
happened to be a church had a lure
enabled on it when he stepped in front
of the church
he could see the man from across the
street hiding behind one of the church
pillars he simply kept walking
pretending like he didn't notice and got
home safely
this was posted only a couple days ago
and has had no update since this whole
story can very easily be true as that
can in a sense be a predators dream come
true a lot of players are on the
authority and certain adults may
familiarize themselves with the app in
order to lure children into quieter
areas so if you play the game
take the loading screen a little
seriously because believe it or not
there has not been a single day since
the game's release without news websites
reporting armed robberies or even dead
body discoveries linked to the game okay
you gotta catch them all right exactly
thank you for my understanding no one
has actually died though from playing
Pokemon go hence hence brilliant line of
crime the fact that you can over people
in interesting Oh shell or movie would
that be just like guys I got I know how
we're gonna rob people what I don't know
what is happening this is weird I was
performing a circumcision and I was
playing Pokemon go huh messed up
everything it's now a girlfriend
yourself this is not on my self circum
circumcision it's a Jewish ritual it's a
medical procedure you don't want to play
pokemon go well now giving a certain
sister oh I get it you get it no Jess I
know my play calling now I know my
calling I will use the app to find these
criminals find bodies I will start
saving the streets of a nice California
it is really cool that they're fighting
the dead Bob they're finding a lot of
games I'll go weird that they're saying
all of these bodies in the creeks
there's no like foul play I think that's
kind of weird why are that people are
just drowning right isn't that weird
that's me I've never been swimming
before let me try it
what wasn't the last story I guess this
kid thought like he might have been
abducted by want the guy from the couple
was just standing there like hiding yeah
where the Pokemon Lord but only you know
like if you learn Taekwondo at a young
age you have nothing to worry about here
nothing fear nothing
when I was a little kid I was like mmm
pedophile bait you know like damn
pedophiles love me hottie I was like
hottie in the pedophile couldn't get any
girls I ever wanted but the pedophiles
they wanted me and still a little bit
like that to this day I learn martial
arts and I was able to fend my way off
of many a pedophile so kids if you're
playing Pokemon go learn some martial
arts because you don't know what's
happening here these people okay a
seriously smart on the criminals to lure
people in like that robbed them because
they don't see that cone they think
they're just playing a game
that's why I would never play his game
that late at night unless I was you know
hunting for criminals right it's funny
that the cops are using it I mean it's
smart for the cops to use I mean if
criminals are using it but often treats
it like they haven't figured something
else out like this that's not Pokemon do
you mean the cops shrew I mean this is a
great way for you know the average since
since you become a police officer
themselves example me I'm gonna go out
there and I'm gonna stop these people
from hurting other people my favorite
one were those girls they were like so
we were playing Pokemon God and we found
about it and it's had no pants
no shirt no shoes no fee it wasn't even
a body there there was nothing I was
like it was just the legs I looked at it
I stood up I turned it on I looked at my
friend with my sister and the legs got
up and just started walking away that
legs it's walked Pokemon go allowed me
to discover supernatural beings out
there who don't need a torso parade
that's my favorite part no feet no ankle
no shoot no shoes either this usually
feet and ankles to go in the shoes
though that's the way their mind work
yeah Oh stuffy no ankles weird but are
there shoes around the second story with
the drug dealers wasn't that big of a
deal
no it's not creepy Benny you're like you
stumble upon a crack see like yeah yeah
the cops were already there it would
have been different if like the drug
dealers not the black guys they were the
victims who were being influenced and
pressured into buying drugs why people
do not sell drugs primarily whites the
whites are evil ain't that right Jesse
and I can back it up
white people are evil blacks rule
abomination the white people they were
dealing drugs and you know what good the
guy was there a witness that white
people are the main drug dealers there's
probably a lot more creepy stories that
haven't been done
oh I'm sure you know okay all honest on
this note one time I was playing Pokemon
go yeah and I walked in to a male strip
club and there was a Pokemon on a you
know a man's Weiner I wouldn't call it a
we're more like a butthole oh yeah I'm
trying not to make too many penis
references these days but on his Buffalo
yes there was a squirrel squirtle
squirtle squirtle look I swear
squirtle I had to catch the squirrel
okay but in order for the squirtle to be
captured he had to fart
so the squirtle would be released this
was a program squirrel inside of this
man Bob yeah is that crazy
that's like this man work with the
company the creators of Pokemon get on
to get squirrel ins blue so that way are
the things that I've been talking about
with you it is subscribe today I'm a
reject
I'm Greg Alba Gregory Angelo Alba
otherwise known IMDB as greg album Jesse
Luca Tuerto
is Italian and awesome kind sweet funny
pretty all of the above
thanks guys who wants to be a
millionaire Jessie does it's really it's
YouTube Shannon it's a grin followed her
there look at her pictures have a fun
time shout out to all the pokemon bill
players and to the pokemon go criminals
keep up the good work